this is what I was really wanting
absolutely yeah Octavia's character
transformation has been so dramatic I
feel like she's not even saying home and
she was she was stepped on earth to you
know the Warriors she's become in season
two I've had a lot of fun learning how
to fight train and you know my own
stunts and it's so much fun to you know
we have real-life action you know super
woman yeah like yeah yeah that was
forever whatever to them yeah there you
go yeah she finally got a horse at horse
training this week so that's what was
coming from yeah I'm over the romance
thing you know they've been they've
named such immense sacrifices for one
another that I feel like that can't
really be compromised you know that
classic Romeo and Juliet romance and it
was linking that showed Octavia who the
tree crew was and that's where she found
out who she really is
and found her place on earth
so they have a really special
relationship together I mean I don't
think Octavia got tipped off too much
growing up under the floor so yeah she's
kidding uh sir
a window was ignited yeah the window
that was like the most exciting moment
of her life she had three seconds in
that dance floor's all over yeah I mean
I always loved the flashback to the back
story because it really helps you
understand where we all came from and
answers a lot of audience questions too
so you get informed you wonder where the
characters go yeah absolutely cuz they
never tell us anything so it's good to
know
you might not know him absolutely
because then you can't anticipate
anything and and it's always amazing
what the writers come up with there's so
many storylines going on simultaneously
at the same time it's crazy ah the
question me as an actor
the sets are just so amazing you know to
feel like that were actually in a tribal
sort of situation with the torches and
the costumes and it's just it really
helps you get into character and really
feel like you're a part of that world
absolutely the rain helps too when
you're drenched and uncomfortable oh my
gosh I've had so much fun learning how
to master the sword and do all my own
stunts somebody's stubborn about it I
like to do everything myself and
kind of blasted yeah you finally gave me
a horse so I get to giddyup around is a
camp Java on that sided with a blast of
pseudo forward to it
you